welcome to this video playing a plus K a
plus K likes under moskalenko to 460 and
is playing the st. George defense with a
six and now maybe transposing to how
it's called hippopotamus yeah very very
hyper modern type of type of play let's
let's see how to how to go about this
mmm p.m. let's play some more
strengthening moves and then see what
what we're going to do is some young
knight d7 and probably f5 ok I prefer
this type of structure or interesting
and that's really interesting I thought
you would go if I've just without any
big hesitation ok i'm just i just opened
up the position and see what happens
cannot be too bad really with the skin
with this bad king ok he just he just
ignores his King position
yeah maybe okay that's Bishop f3 ok
let's a week in a spawn structure a bit
more and now just Bishop b4 maybe yeah
this looks like a simple simple way to
play I mean all these points a week so
it's certainly interesting ok does he
have a desolate ft phone before I can
just take Rukia 323 d4 be seven eggs so
it's um yeah
yeah let's keep it simple maybe I
probably have something better but this
is this is good and relatively easy to
play Bishop d4 was also strong maybe
this was stronger even yeah yes rook f6
which looks which does not look too
attractive but it's playable at least
for the time being but can prepare night
f5 them very quickly played okay yeah if
I think it's already in the mood to win
on time the position is are bad enough
let's see really I just need to check on
g602 to finish this off how would you do
that maybe double on the e-file and I
can take and play rookie 7 this is some
this is winning some material but here's
God is God look-see for at the end which
is a bit unfortunate my back rank is
weak
hmm looks afore i can do 92 no I cannot
very lucky it's very lucky it didn't
even see that okay well I don't need to
exchange queens of the slim that's check
so Queenie to rookie six something like
that
maybe prevent this for the time being
here the time is not not on my side yeah
you really played I'm sorry terribly but
quickly really quickly okay yeah like
him it takes the exchange it's um it's
dope it's still very dangerous
I still must take it
if not I go group g54 rookie six
hmm 40 seconds check check check check
okay just reading this poem 20 seconds
maybe I can do that age 38 Bishop g2
this is important time warning check
okay I manage black forfeit due to this
connection yeah that's somehow fitting
yeah yeah I mean you just played every
move instantly at a crap really sorry
but it was good was very quickly played
yeah around here maybe Bishop g4 is even
better start the same queen bee three
rookie one it's just everything's week
ok this is this is just one way to go
yeah this keeps keeps some edge but it's
probably not not the best way to play
now here may be a form i don't know i
mean i was already a bit confused by the
quick play I thought this would be good
yeah up here this is just as a bit
unlucky that this is not completely
satisfaction
I saw this line and that the NTS got
this one and what am i doing now I
wasn't the back rank is the problem if I
go like here I'm hated and this is not
great what should I do with a compress
Bishop b5 winning maybe because of g4
here i am with the mating mating idea
yeah that's very strong so probably
maybe you should go here then again i
have this check now what's the point i
have a check I can move away with check
and then make sure I'm not mated okay so
then this is winning but I couldn't I
couldn't see that I was irritated by
this rook c4 counterplay so this is why
I didn't go for that and TIR it's it's
still continuing here with them of
course a good position but how do you
actually win rookie seven is strong here
plus three or something okay yeah and
here yeah here you just needs to take
and play this position this is of course
a bit fishy already i didn't i didn't
see this this Bishop g7 I must I must
keep the the bishop protected something
like that which is still pretty good for
white it's got this dead easier okay the
way we we played like a rock g5 is just
instantly winning oh man I didn't really
punish this so I was only glad to to get
to this end game teaches a tank also
very good but yeah this is even better
yeah yeah okay 30 seconds
but he again he blundered this this away
the deep on here's an interesting spot
in age three there's this muth this
might this is always something to watch
out for okay here i can defend it with
this and I have a temper okay but g3
enter g3 enter and h3 is much simpler
the problem is that in addition to this
pawn he also has this bad structure so
he cannot really defend the Queen side
okay thanks for watching